[Music]
and daddy issues new me me me submit buy
something goodbye SOS Rihanna is suing
her father for exploiting her last name
what weight Barba Doris is beyond him
sounds like a dinosaur that's actually
her middle name what yeah we all know
her life we all know her last name
Jackson May I mean think about she's
done Jackson I don't really know that
was Drake she came out with the makeup
line
Rihanna Drake it was just a collab with
fancy no Kevin sees her no she created
that of her makeup but there's efendi
there's like a brand name thing I
thought fancy was a made-up word
me too I thought so too but it's her
last name like a Starbucks venti Robin
Rihanna Fenty I just thought it Rihanna
was a way better choice than Robin yeah
what a dope Leslie then fancy that's
time Rihanna so she's doing her father
why because he has been using the Fenty
cuz his last name is Fenty's he's been
using that name but isn't that okay
fraud drill fraudulently misrepresenting
their company Oh with his business
partner Moses Perkins and so they have
approached them multiple times about
like you know to stop using that name in
different ways like he's trying to be
associated with some sort of like hotel
line and he's booking Rihanna all
through like all Latin America for
fifteen million dollars without
Rihanna's knowledge consent
okay you see trick return yeah her name
and like scamming people he was trying
to he was allegedly trying to negotiate
a deal that would have her play 15 shows
throughout Latin America but all of that
time like she did it was with
permission can you imagine having a bad
that scams people more your name yeah
hold on 15 shows for 15 million that's
so low for her that's such a shitty ass
rate but it's a lot for him and he
probably takes the commission on yeah
like she makes like a few mil off of one
shirt it's not even gonna show up though
yeah her rape very well like I'm I'm
disappointed him as a manager so he's
being charged with like impersonation or
no she's just suing him did he try to
make the logo the same I don't know
logos but I just know that you know he's
been he has never been authorized to use
that name or any telephone name son of a
[ __ ] you know there's a billion Bob's
burger burgers I think maybe where he's
getting in trouble is that he's using
the name to represent Rihanna
cuz if he was just using the name like
this is my own clothing line then he
can't do anything because that's
literally his name yeah no but if he's
saying oh this is Rihanna's line and I
think that's why she can sue him I feel
bad for Rihanna right that's Rihanna got
punched in the face right fine Chris
Brees da she got beat up Miami you know
she actually allegedly recklessly had
talked about how her dad she saw her dad
there in the face to beat her mom oh
okay so she thought it was love but
that's okay is that okay yeah
subconsciously no it's just that she's
talked about how like she didn't have a
good relationship with him because she
witnessed him being abusive she said
this back in 2009 but then in 2012 she's
like I made peace with him so him her
dad or him predict that she's so true
though man you can't say it's hard for
people to escape the the type of
upbringing they had as a kid oh yeah you
can't escape but you did you could just
try your best to learn from it but that
just seeps into you yeah matter what he
looks like a black you half or something
yeah it looks like Ralph Lauren Oh kind
of smug here's another one
you're the beard he looks better with a
beard I agree yeah I heard that too that
familiarity where you're just like oh
man whoo yeah the toxic [ __ ] violent
home and then you you want to recreate
that yeah I think a lot of people have a
trouble understanding that sometimes
because it's not like Rihanna sat there
and when she met Chris Brown she's like
you look like you can punch me in the
face yeah that's tight it's just there's
like patterns that you see that you
don't even know you know that tends to
develop yeah
seeing your parents do it if you do get
hit you kind of just stick around yeah
cuz you saw your mom do it yeah versus
like if you didn't then it's like oh my
god this is crazy I gotta get out of
here yeah I gotta fight against that
[ __ ] is hard I think that's why I like
more times I miss getting my ass beat
the parents don't do it anymore
Sam I need to get hit from time to time
maybe still run to make you some food
after - can you beat me up and make me a
sandwich I don't like yes seaweed it's
like hiring hookers he gets a personal
trainer that [ __ ] is a slob please let
me dump this with only mushrooms inside
please tell me I'm a bad boy I didn't
make my bed
can I get my soy sauce and banana
crackers that's so you like walking
around in a diaper
so what's worse Brianna's mom I don't
know they don't mention her in this
we've seen Jo and Bart in diapers yeah
that was fun there was this viral video
of the two twin babies like talking to
each other indicated that I had to buy
depends and then they put it on it was
so disturbing to sit there and watch
them do this what does depends
adult day oh my grandpa had those well
you so did your friend sitting next to
you I feel like that's something that
you guys would try to do nah oh that
does I'm disappointed I shoot Oh for
science yeah I know I should do my
grandpa he was when he was alive he was
so [ __ ] old we had to put like
depends on him just in case because he
would get up to go use the bathroom but
he was so old and slow we weren't sure
if he was gonna make it
that's sad but it's very cute my
grandma's like that is so cute my god
like I pissed myself it was like one
time where I think he did pee himself
but that's cuz like he was so [ __ ]
close though it looks like somebody
putting molasses on him and he just cute
I'll just watch it gonna my grandma
could pee on herself just from Burpee
I'm not even a senior and I [ __ ] myself
her flutter was probably it's so
sensitive yeah if I jump on a trampoline
like I'm peeing for sure really like it
just there's just no bladder control
there we all pee a little
oh is it true and girls laugh too hard
they pee sometimes you can yeah lifting
lifting too produces excess you're
pushing so hard which kind of lifting
squatting all of it oh yeah even bench
press a little bit yeah I mean if you're
straining yeah that lifting beam happens
a lot actually how come she just doesn't
use [ __ ] like panty liners just a
little bit you know shoot full flow are
you arguing with three women no I just
thought a little pee came out oh really
have you lived it so hard that you just
went I happen to me when I would run six
miles on the treadmill like at around
five and a half miles start peeing but I
it wouldn't there was no warning it
would just like start to go and I'm like
oh my god and I was like pots that were
treadmill but like not like a full you
can stop it you know but like wow it's
like I'm like oh no like it's like the
trampling thing it's I don't know you
just start after drinking that much
water and like running and bouncing does
it hurt when you stop it no because it
it hurts if we stop why Lisa for me
flawed design yeah I think I've been
Britt to take oh my what is it my
bladder I guess is a little bit more
sensitive stuff like I try to over exert
right now then I will be yeah it sucks
so you pee more now you have accidents
more many more well not as much as I
when I first gave birth Oh cuz the
organs all know yes and she Ella said
that too like when she first had her kid
she said like it was hard to it would
just come yeah you sneeze and that's why
you see a lot of moms now and when they
sneeze they cross their legs think
that's you guys like just in case I
always imagine like what are the cave
ladies do they do well they were also
very active so they're Kegel is probably
the Kegel [ __ ] workouts her probably
so is that what kegels are important for
a lot of reason he goes help with that a
lot I didn't know that I was doing a lot
of key goals while I was pregnant so
that it can help me in pushing the baby
out but that goes for the whole not for
the peepee up here well that's you
because you're pushing the baby out
through the hole Oh
yeah but it but when you when you
tighten it it does the whole thing
really the whole thing feel it do it now
the whole know cuz I thought is just
like the kinda like your butthole where
he's just like the opening you don't
feel you're Clint mood yeah do it it
goes all the way up got started from the
bottom now we're here the upper I goes
like this the [ __ ] clench is what is
called yeah this is a little hole this
is the pickle I've heard of surgeries
that they do reconstructive know they
put like some sort of mesh netting yeah
that's when you're older for on the
bladder so they can lift it up cause it
actually detach it oh [ __ ] with age your
butter just tattooed there's actually
like I've heard stories of women like
their shits actually like falling out oh
my god that's so terrifying respected
should we go through I'm done a women
why couldn't the babe I don't think
natural like it for wild animals doing
were supposed to do I don't you know
what happened what if what if the baby
could have just like grow on your
shoulder and then like just when I get
born it's just the skin just I agree
hops up and then the baby crawls on
that's cause you're not used to it no
but everyone would have the baby
oh you're sure oh yeah that's why it's
here because we could protect them okay
imagine if the baby just like grows
above the skin like a blister and it's
like when it's ready then the skin just
pops like a blister I didn't know then
it just kind of heals because it was
like a little window to see that is
[ __ ] disgusting what I call yeah you
can see it yeah
a little tear hat backpacks yeah I think
the best thing would be for it to be
like a shark where you can just do it
outside of the sack and I just do it oh
yeah really big you sit on that once in
a while they invented that where we
talked about it with the she did that
for a sheep oh really
baby lamb or something where they have
this bag and that sheep or lamb whatever
it was like growing it was like a fetus
and just kept all right we need to do
that me too I'm down with that
that's like that short thing were you
tired yeah I'm down with that yeah I
like that better than having it um I
don't think you're gonna be okay we're
not gonna have sex anymore
what like guys and girls oh won't be
needed no cuz then the the reason why I
like fish throw their eggs on the ground
is like guys come over Jack off on it
yeah so it's like that's the way like
humans will start having heard that
humans and dolphins are the only mammals
have sex for pleasure yeah I heard that
mmhmm yeah I hope so
I mean they make a lot of good toys now
maybe maybe not men won't be nice
[Music]